A RUSSIAN MISSILE STRIKE IN AN
APARTMENT BUILDING IN DNIPRO
HAS LEFT 40 PEOPLE DEAD, MAKING
IT ONE OF THE DEADLIEST SINGLE
ATTACKS OF THE WAR.
UKRAINE'S AUTHORITY REPORTS IT
WAS CAUSED BY A MISSILE.
THE ATTACK ON CIVILIAN TARGETS
COMES AT A MAKE-OR-BREAK MOMENT
IN THIS LONG VICIOUS WAR.
DESPITE EARLIER RUSSIAN CLAIMS
A VICTORY, UKRAINE SAYS THERE
IS CONTINUED FEARS AND ONGOING
FIGHTING FOR THE RUSSIAN TOWN
OF SOLID ON.
AND THEY FEAR THAT PUTIN WILL
FIND SOME EXCUSE TO TRY TO
REINVADE FROM THE NORTH.
THE MILITARY WARNS THAT THE
COMBAT TRAILS THAT BEGAN TODAY
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND BELARUS
PRESENT A CLEAR DANGER.
MEANWHILE, MORE WESTERN ALLIES,
INCLUDING BRITAIN, FRANCE AND
POLAND PROMISED TO SEND TANKS
AND OTHER ADVANCED WEAPONS.
BUT, IS IT HAPPENING FAST
ENOUGH?
TO HELP UKRAINE DEFEND ITSELF
TO HELP A RUSSIAN OFFENSE OF
THE SPRING.
WE HAVE A TOP AIDE TO PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY AND HIS CHIEF
DIPLOMATIC JOINING ME NOW FROM
KYIV.
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
AS WE SPEAK, YOUR RESCUE CREWS
ARE STILL DIGGING OUT THAT
APARTMENT BUILDING IN DNIPRO.
DO YOU KNOW THE NUMBER OF DEAD?
DO YOU THINK IT WILL GO HIGHER?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, CHRISTIANA,
WE CAN PREDICT THAT THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS WILL GO HIGHER AS OF
NOW, WHICH IS 40.
THEY HAVE REPORTED OVER 70
WOUNDED, BUT ALMOST 40 ARE NOT
YET FOUND AND THE RESCUE TEAMS
ARE WORKING DAY AFTER DAY, AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT COULD BE EVEN
WORSE.
>> THIS WAS ACCORDING TO YOUR
MILITARY ANALYSIS OF CRUISE
MISSILE SENT TO RUSSIA.
DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO BE THE
NORM?
DO YOU EXPECT MORE OF THAT
AGAINST THOSE KIND OF CIVILIAN
AND RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS?
THEY HAVE DONE AND THEY
CONTINUE TO DO INFRASTRUCTURE,
DO YOU SEE IT MOVING NOW
TOWARDS ACTUAL CIVILIAN
RESIDENCES AND SUCH?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, IT IS MOVING
THAT WAY.
SWABBING BEEN NOT ABLE TO
ACHIEVE ANY SUCCESS IN THE
BATTLEFIELD, THEY STARTED TO
MOVE IN OUR ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE, CRITICAL ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE STARTING FROM
OCTOBER TO FREEZE US FROM THE
WINTERTIME.
NOW WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
WINTER, THEY HAVE NO SUCCESS
PRACTICALLY, SO NOW THEY ARE
MOVING THEIR TACTICS INTO
HITTING DIRECTLY THE MULTI
STORY BUILDINGS, THE PRIVATE
HOUSEHOLDS, USING THIS KIND OF
MISSILES, RIGHT YOU ARE, BUT
IT'S NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO
INTERSECT WITH THE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEM WE ARE NOW IN POSSESSION.
HAD WE HAD ENOUGH WAR
SOPHISTICATED WESTERN TYPE
DEFENSE SYSTEMS, WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO INTERSECT MORE OF THEM,
BUT HAVING WHAT WE HAVE IS
UNFORTUNATELY THE REALITY.
THAT IS WHY MY PRESIDENT IS
TIRELESSLY TALKING TO WORLD
LEADERS.
HE PRACTICALLY STARTED TO DO IT
ON THE FIRST DAY OF THE NEW
YEAR, STARTING HAVING MORE THAN
30 FULL CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
WORLD LEADERS AND NOW IT'S
NUMBER ONE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS, WEAPONS, WEAPONS,
WEAPONS.
>> WHAT KIND, A SPECIFICALLY,
OF ANTI MISSILE DEFENSE DO YOU
NEED?
IS IT THE PATRIOTS?
WE KNOW NOW THAT THE UKRAINIAN
TEAMS HAVE BEING TRAINED BY THE
UNITED STATES, THEY ARE COMING
TO YOU.
WITH THAT MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE?
THIS KIND OF MISSILE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BY THE WAY, OUR SOLDIERS, THEY
ARE REALLY SMART AND QUICK AND
THEY DON'T NEED THAT TRAINING
AS WE ARE TOLD IN THE
BEGINNING.
BUT THAT SYSTEM IS A
MEDIUM-RANGE SYSTEM COMPARED TO
SHORT-RANGE SYSTEM OF SOME
WESTERN COUNTRIES WHO HAVE
ALREADY SUPPLIED TO US, LIKE
IRISH, LIKE OTHER TYPES OF
SYSTEMS, BUT THIS TYPE OF
SYSTEM IS A MEDIUM-RANGE SYSTEM,
BEING ABLE TO INTERSECT THE
TARGETS ON A MORE LENGTHY
DISTANCE.
THAT IS WHY IN THE CASE OF THE
MISSILE, THIS SYSTEM WOULD HAVE
INTERSECTED THIS TYPE OF
MISSILE.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE REALLY
THANKFUL FOR THE U.S. AND TO
SOME OTHER COUNTRIES WHO HAVE
DECLARED DELIVERING SUCH TYPES
OF DEFENSE SYSTEMS.
BUT DEFINITELY WE NEED MORE.
AT LEAST DEFEND EACH MEASURE,
EACH MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> THE BRITISH SECRETARY TODAY
TOLD PARLIAMENT, ACTUALLY THE
DEFENSE SECRETARY TOLD
PARLIAMENT THAT A WHOLE NEW
LEVEL OF NATO AND WESTERN AID
NEEDS TO BE GIVEN TO UKRAINE AT
THIS MAKE-OR-BREAK MOMENT.
YOU WENT VERY, VERY SPECIFIC.
IT REQUIRES A NEW LEVEL OF
SUPPORT, COMBAT POWER WHICH CAN
ONLY BE ACHIEVED BY
COMBINATIONS OF BATTLE TANKS
OPERATING ALONGSIDE ARTILLERY
GROUPS AND FURTHERING DEEP
PRECISION FIRES, ENABLING
TARGETING OF RUSSIAN LOGISTICS
AND COMMANDOES AT GREATER
DISTANCE.
THAT IS FROM BEN WALLACE
HIMSELF, A MILITARY MAN
FORMALLY.
THAT IS VERY DETAILED.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THEY NEED
A WHOLE NEW BATTLE FORMATION.
ARE YOU GETTING, IS THAT WHAT
YOU NEED?
>> YES.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
TO PUT IT MORE SIMPLY, NOTHING
THAT SOPHISTICATED AS WONDERFUL
A PERSON, REALLY AN EXPERT, AND
A PROFESSIONAL AT THIS.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE, WE NEED THIS
TRIAD OF WEAPONS.
APART FROM OUR DEFENSE SYSTEM,
WHICH WE WILL TALK TO YOU ABOUT,
THIS IS AN ARTILLERY SYSTEM.
NOT ONLY ARTILLERY SYSTEM,
WESTERN ARTILLERY SYSTEMS, BUT
THE AMMUNITION.
WE NEED THE AMMUNITION BECAUSE
WE ARE RUNNING OUT OF THE
AMMUNITION FOR THE SOVIET
WEAPONS.
THIRDLY, WE NEED TANKS AND
THESE ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
THE UK SIDE IS ALREADY MADE,
THE EUROPEAN PARTNERS HAS MADE.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE STILL LACK
SOME COUNTRIES TO MOVE THIS
FINAL DECISIVE STEP.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE COUNTING ON
THE MEETING AT THE END OF THIS
WEEK WHERE MORE THAN 50 MINUTES
OF DEFENSE WILL GET TOGETHER
INCLUDING THE MINISTER OF
DEFENSE OF UKRAINE AND REALLY
COUNT ON THE DECISIVE STEPS AND
ACTIONS TO BE MADE IN THIS
MEETING, NOT TO HELP UKRAINE,
NOT ONLY TO WITHSTAND THE
CURRENT ATTACKS OF RUSSIA, BUT
TO MAKE COUNTERATTACKS AND
COUNTEROFFENSIVE IMMEDIATELY.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE, I THINK YOU
ARE CALLING OUT GERMANY, WHICH
HAS NOT YET TAKEN A PUBLIC
DECISION LIKE OTHER EUROPEAN
IDOLIZE FOR THE TANKS AND ALSO
HAS NOT YET GIVEN OFFICIAL
PERMISSION TO OTHER COUNTRIES,
WHICH HAVE THOSE SAME TANKS TO
SEND THEM TO YOU, EVEN THOUGH
THAT THEY ARE WILLING TO DO SO,
SUCH AS POLAND.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS
MINISTRY OF THE U.S. SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE, OTHERS ARE GOING TO
BE MEETING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU HAVE THE DIPLOMATIC
ADVISOR.
DO YOU HAVE ANY HINT THAT
GERMANY WILL COME THROUGH LIKE
THE OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE?
>> YOU KNOW TOMORROW IS A VERY
IMPORTANT DAY, THE ANNIVERSARY
OF DIPLOMATIC RELATIONS BETWEEN
GERMANY.
BUT RIGHT YOU ARE.
I HAVE A CAUTIOUS OPTIMISM
ABOUT THE DECISION INCLUDING ON
THE COUNTRY YOU MENTIONED TO BE
TAKEN THIS FRIDAY DURING THE
MEETING.
REALLY WE HAVE A LOT FROM
GERMANY, BUT SOMETIMES YOU NEED
TO MAKE THIS VERY IMPORTANT
DECISION TO GAIN THE MOMENTUM.
REMEMBER WHAT WAS HAPPENING TO
OUR DEFENSES DUMB, SOMEBODY HAS
TO BE FIRST AND THEN YOU FOLLOW
THEM.
WE WOULD LIKE GERMANY TO MAKE
THIS VERY IMPORTANT STEP.
>> IT APPEARS, AND AGAIN YOU
ARE THE DIPLOMATIC ADVISOR,
THAT ANY IDEA OF ANY
NEGOTIATIONS OR SOME KIND OF
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
IN TERMS OF A PEACE DEAL, IT'S
JUST SO FAR OFF, THAT'S WHAT IT
APPEARS LIKE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU WHAT YOU MAKE
OF PRESIDENT PUTIN TELLING THE
PRESIDENT OF TURKEY THAT IT'S
ALL BECAUSE OF WESTERN, NATO
WEAPONS, THEY ARE PROLONGING
THIS.
THEY HAVE ALREADY BLAMED THE
DNIPRO BUILDING ATTACK ON THE
UKRAINIAN SUPPLIED MISSILE
DEFENSE SYSTEM SAYING IT WAS
YOUR MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEMS
THAT WENT INTO THAT BUILDING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF PUTIN'S
CONVERSATION WITH THE TURKISH
PRESIDENT?
>> IT'S A FALSE NARRATIVE.
I CAN NAME YOU MIGHT MENTION
THE RUSSIANS SAY THAT THIS IS
UKRAINE, UKRAINE WANTS MORE.
UKRAINIANS ARE DYING, BEING
WOUNDED AND THEY DON'T WANT ONE
TO HAVE PEACE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY WHO IS
TRYING FOR PEACE, WAS TALKING
ABOUT THIS FROM THE FIRST DAYS
AND SUGGESTED A VERY SIMPLE WAY
OUT.
THE TEN POINT PEACE FORMULA.
THE PRESIDENT SUGGESTED THAT TO
MANY OF THE WORLD LEADERS AND
THEY HAVE NOT HAD ANYTHING
AGAINST THIS FROM ANY SINGLE
WORLD LEADER, EXCEPT FOR ONE,
YOU JUST MENTIONED PRESIDENT
PUTIN HIMSELF.
HE DOES NOT WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
THERE IS A FORMULA WITH NINE
POINTS OF DEPRIVING RUSSIA OF
THE AGGRESSIVE INSTRUMENTS.
DEPRIVING ALL OF US FROM SUPPLY
FROM UKRAINE IS ALSO
AGGRESSION.
MAKING AN ENVIRONMENTAL
DISASTER IS ALSO AGGRESSION.
ET CETERA.
EVEN THE STATUTE OF THE U.N. IS
ALSO AN AGGRESSION.
LET'S COMBINE OUR EFFORTS
TOGETHER TO THE WORLD LEADERS.
THEN, THAT WILL BRING US TO
PEACE BECAUSE ANY WAR, ANY
VICTORY ENDS UP AT THE
NEGOTIATION TABLE.
SHULL >> IGOR ZHOVKVA, CHIEF
DIPLOMATIC ADVISER, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.